we had a very special moment in
right-wing propaganda yesterday ben
shapiro and tucker carlson
both had clips that are top entries into
dumbest take of the day i'm gonna play
both of the clips for you i want you to
decide which is the dumb or take of the
two videos i'm gonna play for you today
we have exhibit a exhibit a is a clip
from the tucker carlson program on fox
news interviewing i guess he still is
considered comedian adam carolla and
they talk about political correctness
around gendering people and i actually
can't tell if the clip is comedy or
political commentary it's either really
unfunny comedy or really stupid
political commentary that's clip number
one now on a normal day that clip which
i'll show you in a second would be the
dumbest take of the day from right-wing
media but then in comes ben shapiro who
claimed that anyone who has a second job
simply has failed themselves it's poor
people's fault that their one job
doesn't pay enough and that they need a
second job and it's their fault so we
have a competition here for dumbest clip
of the day yesterday
first Tucker and Adam take a look it's
and I would say drop them off in a
business and let them be what they used
to call me on the construction site
start off as a glorified Goom per which
is low man on the totem pole ooh can we
say low man anymore no lo what well I
don't want to I don't want to use a
pejorative here and assign no the
pronoun is de lo they not on the totem
pole because that's cultural
appropriation point low they on the
barber pole no lo they on the flagpole
no definite on the flagpole on the
utility pole low they on the telephone
pole yeah so the premise here is oh
isn't college a scam and then they're
getting into are you allowed to say low
man on the totem pole because everyone
on the left and everyone in colleges is
so politically correct again is this
comedy if so it's just not funny is this
political commentary if so it's really
stupid so that's option a alright let's
now look at option beef
duh mistake of the day from yesterday
here's ben shapiro on people who have
jobs that don't pay well and on people
who have two jobs well the fact is that
if you had to work more than one job to
have a roof over your head or food on
this table you probably shouldn't taken
the job that's not paying you enough
that'd be a you problem also it is not
true the vast majority of people in the
United States are working two jobs it
just is not true according to the census
statistics a small but steady number of
American workers have more than one job
because either they need extra income or
because they want to gain more
experience or explore different
interests there's a recently released US
Census Bureau report and apparently what
it found is that approximately eight
point three percent this is up as of
2013 so it's actually lower now eight
point three percent of workers had more
than one job that was as of 2013 it's a
lot lower now so this notion that there
are just tons and tons of people who are
working at multiple jobs it is not
really true it's not actually the
reality in May five percent of Americans
had multiple jobs five percent that's
really what's bringing down the
unemployment rate is those five percent
of workers who have multiple jobs okay
for all of the talk about people working
in uber it's it's held to that range
actually really since 2009 it's always
been a very very low number so this
again is just a lie it is also this this
bizarre idiocy that you can dictate to
the economy what the economy ought to do
every time everybody tries to dictate to
the economy what it ought to do the
economy fights back because it turns out
the aggregate knowledge of the market
economy knows more than you do I know
shocking how is it an individual
person's job that said a different way
because I don't want to use the term job
in both cases how is it an individual
person's fault that most jobs don't pay
that well in the bottom half of the
economy and that wages have been
stagnant for the bottom half of workers
for decades Ben is right about one thing
the number of people actually working
two jobs is pretty small but it's still
bigger than he wants to admit I mean
five percent is still one out of 20 if
you go to the supermarket and there are
you know a hundred people there five of
those people are likely working two jobs
that's not nothing okay but it's not
huge I will give him that but the really
dumb part of it is if you had to work
more than one job it's your fault that
your main job doesn't pay enough even
though you have no control over the
distribution of jobs and the wages that
are available in the economy if there
are only so many jobs that pay well you
can't control that right this is
actually the epitome of that cartoonish
childish libertarian idea that a 16 year
old hears about an R and reads one book
and now believes this even though they
don't really understand anything about
how the economy or the world works
combined with the sort of abject cruelty
of modern conservatism it's the kind of
delusional worship of free markets and
Liberty that these people fall into
typically before they know anything ben
shapiro comes from a relatively you know
upper middle-class family thinks that
even if he didn't he would still have
found a good job period simply because
he's determined to do it the idea that
you might have to choose from the
available jobs even if it's a job that
doesn't pay well or even if it's two
jobs that don't pay well because you've
got to pay your bills and you have no
parents to bail you out that doesn't
even enter into ben Shapiro's mind I
actually don't think he's being
disingenuous here I think this is a
combination of his personal privileged
position in society
combined with cartoonish right-wing
economic ideas combined with a complete
lack of empathy
I think that that's what it is I don't
believe he's being deliberately
disingenuous I think he's just clueless
and somehow hasn't got gotten out of
those childish libertarian ideas that 16
year-olds often pick up and then lose by
the time they get to college and learn
how the world actually works this is
what I call right-wing politics brought
to you by a privileged upbringing and a
complete lack of empathy that's how you
get to this so my question to you is
which is the worst take is it Tucker
Carlson and Adam Carolla or is it Ben
Shapiro I think that the Tucker one is
more cartoonishly stupid but the ben
shapiro one is more dangerous because it
represents a common american
conservative worldview that's completely
disconnected from reality and it gets
people supporting bad Paul
see it gets people seeing the world in a
way that is totally unrealistic and
thinking that really bad ideas are
actually really good ideas so I think if
I had to vote cartoonishly stupid Adam
Carolla again you know I don't have to
get back into it dangerous when it comes
to actually making political progress in
this country ben shapiro and the ideas
that he puts out there particularly
because he puts them out there by
talking really quickly and confidently
as we've analyzed before in a way that
people hear it and they're just
overwhelmed by what seen seems like just
crystal clear and perfect logic let me
know what you think and make sure that
you are following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show while
you're there follow me on instagram at
david pakman we'll take a quake a quick
break not a quake we'll take a quick
break a lot more coming up today today's
program brought to you in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a great
service that I use all the time what
they do is they take thousands of the
most popular non-fiction books including
the newest bestsellers they condense
them into 15-minute audiobooks that you
can listen to and you still get the most
crucial information and insights from
each book and I've listened to a ton of
books on blink as' I recently checked
out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber
which I listened to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you'd like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month that's be Li NK
is t.com /pa k mas